[Music]  hello you know you gotta pay for that  right  hey not okay we got ourselves an x-men  fan maybe a quarter of it happens and  not let this in the real world people  die Logan I don't want to talk about it  Logan just stop be careful  I need the girl baccarat go Vienna  now no no  oh she's liked you very much like you oh  I'm not whatever it is you think I am  she needs our help doesn't want to come  off someone has come along  this is what life looks like  people love each other  you should take a moment  Sheila  you still have time  [Music]  two days on the road only one meal and  hardly any sleep she's 11 I'm [ __ ] 90  the only thing that's real they need  this she's like you of time very much  like you